kaddour l'on a c'est quoi ce bruit là
bas tu l'entends tout aussi bien mais
moi je crois que mes oreilles siffler
parce que tu pensé à moi
c'est ça
[Musique]
vous avez tous atteints t'attends tu
veux pas qu'on arrête ce bruit avant de
tourner il ya plus bourru heures en fait
mais moi je n'entends toujours pas les
oreilles qui sifflent
comment ça c'est justement c'est ce que
je l'avais expliqué vous avez tous que
nous ça et ceux qui n'ont pas encore
connu finiront bien par le connaître les
oreilles qui sifflent
ça s'appelle des acouphènes alors
parfois ça apparaît comme ça juste une
fois on sait pas trop pourquoi
ou alors après un coup sur l'oreille
après un gros bruit et ça finit par
passer
mais parfois ça passe puis ça revient
puis ça passe puis ça revient
et des fois même mais ça passe pas du
tout ça reste tout le temps ça touche 10
à 15% de la population adulte et rien
qu'en france tout cas confondues on
parle quand même de 16 millions de
personnes alors pour être d'accord sur
les termes un acouphène oui c'est
masculin et un mac ou fun un acouphène
c'est un bruit qu'on entend mais qui
vient pas de l'extérieur c'est une
impression auditive si vous voulez
attention ça n'a rien à voir avec une
hallucination auditive eu une
hallucination non non non non rien à
voir une hallucination auditive c'est un
trouble dans lequel on entend une voix
de la musique ce genre de choses là
c'est un son qu'on entend en continu et
on rêve on dit qu'on a les oreilles qui
sifflent
mais pas toujours exactement le cas ça
peut être un sifflement donc mais ça
peut aussi être un bourdonnement
grésillement le bruit d'un jet de vapeur
le bruit du vent le chant des cigales
n'importe quel bruit indéfinissable mais
énervant bon alors c'est quoi ces bruits
d'où ils viennent
bah on sait pas vraiment où mais ce
qu'on sait c'est que dans 80 à 90% des
cas les acouphènes sont associés à une
baisse de l'audition soit parce que ben
voilà c'est la vie on vieillit soit à
cause de maladies de l'appareil auditif
soit après des traumatismes physiques ou
sonores etc
donc du coup on entend moins bien ok
mais qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi il
ya ces bruits vu que vos oreilles
alors une seule où les deux ans ça
dépend des cas vu vos oreilles elle
entend de moins bien
votre cerveau et plus particulièrement
la zone qui s'occupe des sons et qui
s'appelle le cortex auditif
il se dit qu'il faut essayer de faire
quelque chose pour arranger ça il a
trifouiller un peu les réglages mais en
essayant de s'adapter a provoqué une
activité inhabituelle au niveau du
système auditif et votre système nerveux
central lui il va identifier ça comme un
saut résultat votre cerveau il vous dit
a bien un brûleur alors qu'en fait non
pas du tout donc on dit qu'on a les
oreilles qui sifflent
mais en réalité bien souvent c'est dans
la tête que le son est produit ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'on n'est pas tous
égaux devant les acouphènes
pour certains ça va juste être une
petite gêne pour d'autres ça va être
très handicapant heureusement ce cas là
c'est rare c'est moins d'un pour cent
des cas mais quand même ça peut donner
des troubles du sommeil des troubles de
la concentration et ça peut même jouer
sur le moral
en gros on comprend pas trop ce qui se
passe donc on stresse et il se trouve
que le stress bas ça augmente les
acouphènes
du coup c'est un cercle vicieux ça peut
même aller jusqu'à la dépression et
c'est encore pire si les gens autour de
vous ils comprennent pas trop où s'il
croit que vous exagérez tout ça c'est
oui c'est dans la tête
c'est vrai mais c'est un problème réel
et il faut pas le négliger
bombay le mieux c'est de ne pas en
arriver là c'est ne pas avoir
d'acouphènes mais pour ça il faut savoir
pourquoi on peut en avoir
les principaux facteurs de risque c'est
le vieillissement de l'oreille et les
traumatismes sonores bon pour le
vieillissement apparaître vie
on va y revenir il n'y a pas grand chose
à faire rien je vous conseille en tout
cas par contre pour les traumatismes
sonores
là on va faire quelque chose le bruit ça
fait diminuer l'audition principalement
parce que ça détruit des cellules
sensorielles qu'on a là tout au fond de
l'eau règne dans ce qu'on appelle
l'organe de corti ces cellules on les
appelle des cellules ciliées
parce qu'elles ont des petits seal qui
réagissent aux vibrations produites par
les sons elle les transforme en influx
nerveux pour envoyer l'information à des
neurones qui vont eux-mêmes l'envoyer
jusqu'au cerveau par le son est pas trop
fort
pas de soucis mais quand le volume
augmente les cils sont abîmés puis ils
sont détruits et les acouphènes
s'installe et ça peut aller jusqu'à la
surdité
donc l'idée pour se protéger c'est de
limiter son exposition au bruit dans la
durée et en intensité
le seuil de risque ces 85 décibels c'est
à dire à peu près une cantine scolaire
sais pas si vous vous souvenez quelques
heures par jour à 85 décibels ou même
juste une heure si c'est de la musique
que vous écoutez au casque et vous
commencez déjà à m florian lang à 100
décibels quelques minutes suffisent et
même quelques secondes si vous êtes
exposés à 112 décibels pour vous donner
une idée en boîte par exemple on est à
100 110 décibels en moyenne et ça peut
monter jusqu'à 115 warsan en aidant les
concerts c'est pire on est facilement à
120 décibels voir 138 si on est devant
la scène est presque 140 si on est à
côté des ensembles alors pour info un
avion qui décolle c160 décibels et la
douleur elle apparaît à 120
alors on a vu qu'on n'est pas tous égaux
devant les lésions
mais quand même selon une étude
française 70% des musiciens de rock ont
des troubles auditifs et des 26 ans 75%
des dj qui travaillent au moins trois
nuits par semaine ont des acouphènes
donc en boîte
éloignez vous des enceintes pareil en
concert on mettait des bouchons
d'oreille ils ont distribué partout non
dans les deux cas est partout c'est
bruyant faites des pauses en allant vous
mettre au calme
régulièrement dehors aux toilettes où
vous voulez mais faites des pauses quand
vous écoutez de la musique ou des vidéos
au casque déjà évité les écouteurs intra
auriculaires c'est les plus violents
pour refixer le pilier
choisissez plutôt un casque qui vont
prend bien les oreilles si possible avec
un réducteur de bruits extérieurs comme
ça ça vous évitera de monter le sombre
couvrir bon j'avoue c'est un peu plus
cher mais franchement si vous pouvez
voler vous pouvez aussi régler les
appareils que vous utilisez pour
améliorer la qualité du son pour ça je
vous mets des liens dans la description
de la vidéo
et attention vous faites pas avoir vous
avez peut-être entendu dire que la loi
était modifiée et que maintenant le
volume sonore est limité c'est vrai mais
c'est limité à 100 décibels pour les
casques c'est bien au dessus de la
limite de risquer à 85 décibels comme on
l'a vue donc
n'écoutez pas avec le volume sonore afin
pour les boîtes et les concerts s'est
limité à 100 2 décibels
donc là encore c'est suffisant pour
choper des acouphènes
mais maintenant vous savez quoi faire
alors peut-être que vous n'allez pas en
boîte peut-être que vous n'allez pas
dans les bars en festivals où un concert
mais peut-être que vous êtes exposés au
bruit à votre boulot dans ces cas la
demande et des protections auditives à
votre boss et n'hésitez pas fait
intervenir la médecine du travail si
besoin bien sûr il ya d'autres causes
pour les acouphènes la même plaint le
meilleur conseil que je puisse vous
donner c'est ne laissez pas traîner
si vous avez l'impression que vous avez
un souci que vous entendez moins bien
etc
c'est valable pour les gens qui ont
atteint un certain âge mais ça marche
pour tout le monde par exemple si vous
prenez des médicaments genre des anti
inflammatoires des corticoïdes certains
antibiotiques ou n'importe quel
médicament qui peut être auto toxiques
c'est à dire
mais les oreilles ça vous savez pas
forcément donc soyez vigilents est
consultée au moindre souci
aller chez le médecin dans les 24 heures
surtout si ça paraît brutale
dernière chose n'utilisez pas de coton
tige arrêter de faire ça ça pousse le
cérumen dans le fond ça fait des
bouchons et ça aussi ça peut provoquer
des acouphènes
alors je vais pas vous laisser dans
l'angoissé oui les acouphènes ça soigne
mais à part quand il ya une cause très
précises qu'on peut traiter on en guérit
rarement par contre on peut diminuer
leur intensité et leur conséquence pour
ça il ya tout un arsenal de traitement
ça va de la prothèse qui diffuse en
continu un petit son qui parasite et qui
couvre les acouphènes aux thérapies
cognitives et comportementales avec un
psy pour apprendre à vivre avec
on appelle ça le phénomène l'habituation
en passant évidemment par tout ce qui
est une méditation sophrologie et sert à
ça même bien donc maintenant vous savez
pourquoi on a les oreilles qui sifflent
mais vous savez surtout comment ne pas
avoir les oreilles qui sifflent c'est
bien dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo
d'ici là on espère que vous prenez soin
des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]